alla terra avevo 38 anni due figlie un
bel lavoro quando una sera mio marito
venuto a casa mia detto fra due mesi ci
trasferiremo a vivere negli stati uniti
è stato un bello shock anche perché ne
avevamo parlato sì ma solo a livello di
idea non di fatto concreto abbiamo
vissuto a washington dc per tre anni tre
magnifici anni devo dire anche se
ricordo i primi sei mesi come un periodo
particolarmente difficile quando
l'esperienza è finita ho voluto capire
meglio che cosa mi era successo e
studiando ho realizzato che quello che
era accaduto a me sorpresa sorpresa
accade a tutti quelli che si
trasferiscono all'estero e di quel
periodo ho imparato una lezione che oggi
condivido con voi e cioè che adattarsi e
più facile che resistere quanti di voi
hanno mai pensato di trasferirsi
all'estero per lavoro studio
semplicemente per cercare un altro posto
dove vivere
parecchi bene questa è la mia casa di
washington
e questo il paesaggio a cui eravamo
abituati siete in buona compagnia perché
sono oltre 4 milioni 200 mila italiani
che oggi vivono all'estero circa il 73
per cento della popolazione italiana
quindi numeri non piccoli andare a
vivere all'estero è una grande
opportunità una straordinaria avventura
un elemento di arricchimento a tutte le
età ma è anche una grande sfida qui
arrivare preparati perché quando
l'occasione diventa concreta oltre
all'entusiasmo cominciano le paure le
ansie i dubbi ce la farò ad adattarmi a
vivere in un paese diverso dal mio
ce la farà da imparare una nuova lingua
nuove abitudini a farmi nuovi amici e ci
preoccupiamo sempre molto degli aspetti
pratici del trasferimento trovare una
casa che cosa portare organizzare il
trasloco in realtà queste sono le cose
più facili da gestire
nella mia esperienza
americana vi racconto due piccoli
episodi accaduti all'inizio che servono
per introdurre il tema il primo giorno
di lavoro mio marito va a lavorare
naturalmente come si usa in italia si
presenta al lavoro investito formale
giacca cravatta camicia stirata scarpe
inglesi il classico gessato salò
arrivare e trovare un mare di t shirt di
pantaloni informali
c'è qualcosa che non va il primo sabato
sera alcuni colleghi di lavoro ci
invitano a cena sono molto gentili gli
americani vogliono subito coinvolgerti e
naturalmente sabato sera andiamo con un
abbigliamento rilassato un po casual
salvo scoprire che tutti gli altri sono
vestiti eleganti come per una cerimonia
c'è decisamente qualcosa che non va dopo
pochi giorni cominciano ad arrivare
degli inviti per delle feste siamo in
giugno apre l'invito e penso sarà una
festa in giardino i nostri vicini ci
vogliono coinvolgere nella piccola
comunità del nostro quartiere
apro l'invito e resta scioccata c'è
scritto save the heat il nostro party
sarà il 10 novembre dalle 19 alle 21 e
io penso ma e se accetto e quel 10
novembre sono morte che figura ci faccio
e se poi alle 21 me ne vado cosa succede
mi buttano fuori
ma perché si comportano così perché come
si dice è la cultura bellezza il modo di
comportarsi delle persone è determinato
dalla loro cultura e anche se noi non ce
ne accorgiamo il modo in cui noi ci
relazioniamo agli altri e agiamo nella
vita di tutti i giorni è condizionato da
quello che abbiamo appreso fin da
bambini
vivendo in un certo gruppo in un certo
paese e in un certo specifico momento
storico
quindi quando abbiamo a che fare con
altre persone che vengono da altri paesi
è inevitabile che ci sia uno scontro tra
culture
la cultura è sicuramente visibile nei
nostri comportamenti quotidiani ma
permea la nostra vita in maniera ancora
più profonda è legata a tutto quello che
noi pensiamo facciamo al modo in cui ci
comportiamo ai nostri atteggiamenti alle
nostre percezioni
questa è una cava
letta e voi direte un semplice animale
si è un semplice animale ma questo
animale è considerato una piaga in nord
america e in europa è considerato un
animale domestico in molti posti della
cina è considerato un ottimo antipasto
in thailandia se anche un animale così
piccolo è percepito è costruito nel suo
significato culturalmente immaginatevi
che cosa succede con le persone quello
che ci succede quando incontriamo
culture diverse dalla nostra è che
subiamo quello che viene definito il
calcio choc ma il calcio shock non è un
evento è un processo e cerchiamo di
vederlo assieme perché arrivarci
preparati e la cosa più importante
all'inizio viviamo qualche giorno in cui
tutto sembra irreale
siamo appena arrivati e ci sembra di
vivere in un sogno
subito dopo abbiamo una fase di grande
entusiasmo si chiama la luna di miele
tutte nuove eccitanti interessante ci
piace scoprire guardare vedere tutto in
una luce romantica purtroppo questa fase
dura solo poche settimane dopo di che
cominciano i problemi
non siamo in vacanza siamo lì per
restare e cominciano a sperimentare
tutte le difficoltà di vivere in un
ambiente che non è il nostro le
difficoltà di comunicare con gli altri
le resistenze tutto ci sembra irritante
le persone il clima al cibo le abitudini
finché tocchiamo il fondo abbiamo molti
sentimenti negativi frustrazione ansia
paura difficoltà senso di incompetenza
incomunicabilità è difficile vivere da
stranieri in una terra straniera e
quando siamo in questa fase solitamente
utilizziamo come tutte le persone due
comportamenti gli stereotipi e
l'etnocentrismo gli stereotipi sono
ovviamente delle generalizzazioni delle
schematizzazioni molto rigide di
caratteristiche che attribuiamo a un
gruppo di persone anche se in realtà
appartengono a degli individui volete
degli esempi
i tedeschi sono tutti i rigidi gli
svizzeri puntuali gli italiani molto
romantici i francesi arroganti gli
americani ignoranti ma ha proposto di
ignoranza
voi sapete dove a buffalo qualcuno lo sa
no baciano la seconda città più
importante dello stato di new york dal
new york city stato di new york
vedete siamo ignoranti anche noi come
del resto credo che pochi di noi
sappiano qual è la capitale del new
mexico santa fe oppure del dell'alabama
montgomery del mississipi jackson
eppure gli stati uniti sono molto più
grande e più popolosi dell'europa ma noi
non sappiamo quali sono le loro capitali
ma pensiamo che gli americani sono
ignoranti perché spesso non sanno che
parigi bruxelles non sono entrambe in
francia quindi gli stereotipi sono
facili da ribaltare
un'altra arma che utilizziamo el'altro
centrismo cosa facciamo pensiamo che la
nostra cultura sia la migliore
etnocentrismo letteralmente vuol dire
mettere il proprio gruppo al centro
attribuire una superiorità intrinseca al
proprio modo di agire alla propria
cultura
noi italiani quando andiamo all'estero
la facciamo sempre il nostro cibo il
migliore di tutti gli altri
siamo gli unici a sapersi vestire
recentemente al mondo il nostro paese è
il più bello in assoluto ma non siamo
gli unici a fare questo per tutti è così
quello che succede nella nostra famosa
curva è che una volta superata questa
fase
impariamo a risalire impariamo nuove
strategie ci facciamo nuovi amici
capiamo come comportarci e finalmente
torna anche la fiducia in se stessi
l'equilibrio la voglia di stare con gli
altri e fino a quando ci integriamo
siamo di nuovo a casa
finalmente abbiamo capito che il paese
ospite la nostra nuova casa sappiamo
distinguere gli aspetti positivi e
negativi della cultura di origine della
cultura di partenza tutti quanti
passiamo attraverso questo processo
quando andiamo in un paese straniero
ovviamente questo processo è più o meno
lungo più o meno intenso a seconda di
chi siamo noi di che esperienza abbiamo
precedentemente e anche di quanto
distante la cultura di origine da quella
di arrivo quello che è importante però è
conoscere questo processo in anticipo
esserne
lì per poter affrontare meglio la
l'esperienza perché alla fine adattarsi
e più facile che resistere grazie